lui est la saison du tourisme en france
et depuis quelques années on ne compte
plus le nombre d'éco musée consacré
comme le nom l'indiqué l'économie à
l'industrie d'une région et les
touristes s'intéressent désormais non
seulement donc on visite artistique mais
aussi aux usines comme cette brasserie
alsacienne qui offre un parcours
initiatique à ces visites
reportage christine bost sylvain
gauthier il ya des signes qui ne
trompent pas gera bien mi mousses nous
sommes dans une des dernières brasserie
alsacienne indépendante et familiale des
coeurs en 1640 que c'est devenu
l'entreprise commerciale ainsi touristes
et amateurs de bière ce prestigieux
groupe trois fois par semaine pour
découvrir par quel miracle le mélange
d'eau de malt et de houblon va donner
naissance à la bière
on visite plus on vient plus dans une
région pour juste se poser mais ya ce
qu'on appelle le tourisme industriel
c'est à dire on veut savoir comment est
fait le produit
comment il est fabriqué avec quoi avec
du houblon bien sûr cette gallen en
prévoir donc en phase de brassage
l'opération 21h30 d'un parcours au pas
de charge pour épancher la soif de
connaissance de visiteurs très curieux
surtout savoir à parce qu'il ya quand
même différente à différentes étapes de
la chaîne donc à devoir jazz d'avant
centre de l'asean l'embouteillage
justement toujours spectaculaire surtout
à raison de 50 mille bouteilles par
heure est au bout du marathon la
dégustation bières à volonté et
commentaires
on peut déguster après effectivement ce
qu'on a vu fabriquer que c'est très bon
même les cigognes ne s'y sont pas
trompés en s'installant sur le toit de
la brasserie